yo yo welcome back to the edge with your
boy Michael Parsons live in your
Bleacher Report app as always drop any
questions comments in the chat and I
respond during the show what's up what's
up Cowboys Nation how we feeling huge
Thanksgiving win uh doesn't matter an
opponent anytime you get to be thankful
and share the field with your brothers
and another team and everyone leaves the
field uh safe and uninjured is always a
great game so uh that's something to be
thankful for I hope everyone's thanksgiv
was amazing mom was amazing family came
into town anytime family comes in it's
just so amazing to have people around
people that you love so if you had
amazing Thanksgiving uh shout out to you
but anyway let's get right into it they
want to talk about the Thanksgiving fit
of mine um the ideas the thoughts the
the emotions behind this fit I want to
First say you know I wanted to come out
because this is the America's team and I
just felt like I was like an American
Gangster uh you know Frank Lucas just
like that you know me and my guy Ricky
uh SoDo and Co shout out to SoDo and co
uh for putting this together but uh that
blue magic right there that's kind of
how I was feeling um with the drape coat
I wanted to bring it back like I was in
the 90s so that's kind of you know
something special that we put together
and the energy look at the fans uh the
energy running to the stadium again
that's what we love to see I think
that's what's different about Cowboys
Nation how thrilled they are look how
how excited they are to be into the
stadium how exciting they are to be with
us um because they know it's going to be
an amazing day and it was we did make
history that day in a lot of ways and
we're going to get into that a little
bit look at this Thanksgiving sign um I
mean the fan C there's nobody like
Cowboys Nation that's Point Bank period
um Dak and cheese pilot and greens
Parson poie and CD lamb that's a 10 out
of 10 sign right there and that needed
to be plastered all over walls uh for
every Thanksgiving and that's just
simple as that uh people want to talk
about halftime shows I was not able to
watch any halftime shows sadly uh but
Dolly partman and Jack Jack harlo I was
not able to watch any those halftime
show um but you know I heard a lot of
comments about it and you know my mother
always told me if there's not nothing to
say something nice to say don't say it
at all so that's just kind of how I feel
about it um and we got some cool stats
and records at home that you guys should
obviously know
um Cowboys have not Trail a single
second at home it just goes to show you
how good we are at home and guess who's
that because that's because of Cowboys
Nation I understand we travel and y'all
make some games for like home games and
the energy is amazing but there's just
nothing like playing at home in front of
you guys because you guys take it to
another level um at this point we need
to win out and do everything in our
possible so we could be at home with you
guys multiple times um this postseason
because it's going to be very fun uh uh
something cool cool about me that you
know they felt like we should share to
the world um I joined Dwight fre and
Reggie Wy the only players with 11 plus
sacks in each of their first three
seasons so it's kind of something I feel
proud of uh something I take a lot of
work into um going into how I want to
how great I want to be um I just gota be
continuous though I never want to stop
uh I want to keep being great um daring
to be great and keep chasing these guys
cuz you talking about two of the best to
ever do it you know Dwight freeny and
obviously Reggie White was man amongst
men and he was one of the greatest ever
if not the greatest ever um but the big
story is not about me I'm always believe
it's all about my teammates and the
biggest story of them all is Don Bland
uh record setting five interceptions
pick sixes five pick sixes for return
for touchdowns in one season holy moly I
mean th this is greatness um we don't
have it but there was a clip where I
went up to him I was like this is
greatness you're on track of greatness
because people don't understand how
special it is how how amazing it is to
see that out of your teammates it it's
truly just it it's one thing and I and I
think sometimes we all don't live in the
moment we don't live in the present and
everything just moves so fast especially
as a an adult I think we all learn to
grow about that but everything just
moves fast as do it's like all right
tomorrow tomorrow but I just want to
recapture and relive that moment for DB
um that is amazing for you champ um that
that is just one of a kind you are leg
already um and and I I couldn't be more
proud of you um this is the energy in
the locker room um I mean th this is
something that like you you could tell
the energy and everyone how quiet he is
um this is definitely not his type of
moment um that's the type of player and
uh friend he is you know he don't never
want to be the main stage but we are so
proud of him he had to get that type of
moment um Darius Slay and I say that he
should be defensive player of the year
and and that's 100% right um I mean he
is playing the best football I mean he's
playing out better than any Corner um
and the NFL right now uh he has a knack
for the ball and and there's a lot of
players that's playing great Corner ball
and it it's they're playing really high
level but no one's creating his
turnovers um and I think I think what
will lock it and how he goes against uh
the Eagles again next week uh he has DK
metf and Tyler Lockett again this week
uh he'll also have a chance that Stefan
Diggs and Gabe Davis and he'll also have
a chance that Tyreek Hill jayen wildad
um I think if he could sustain this for
these next four or five weeks he will be
a lock for defense player of the year
without a doubt and I think also it'll
be in a conversation for MVP if he could
create two more turnovers for
interceptions um because right now if
he's not a lock already a defense player
of the year which he should be uh he
will be a lock by the end of the year if
he keeps going and maybe get in our
conversation for MVP cuz this is a
season that no one's ready for um and I
think we should honestly get into who
who could be in my top MVP candidate
because you know Dak Prescott he's
playing the best football uh he had
another big game 22 for 32 331 yards and
four touchdowns um Dak even grabbed a
turkey leg out the Salvation Army Kettle
in the fourth quarter um that was always
dak's idea he was like y know there's
turkey legs in the bottom of the uh
Salvation Army thing but I mean bro like
he is playing Amazing football um
leading in touchdowns uh I mean he's his
qbr is number one in the league he is
playing great football I mean I couldn't
be more happy for this guy he proved a
lot of people wrong and people want to
bring down his amazing season because
he's putting a lot of people to hush and
a lot of people don't like that but I
love to see that for him he proved
everyone wrong and he's going to
continue to do that he just keep getting
better and better and leading into this
postseason I know we could count on
him um so I think my if I had a idea of
who my MVP conversation would be um
obviously it would be Dak Prescott um it
would be actually let's just wait
because we'll get into a little bit more
because uh the bills Eagles game uh that
was huge the bill the Eagles outlasted
the bills 3734 OT um and the first and
they're the first team to 10 wins um
what was my biggest takeaways this game
I mean I feel like this was this is what
a Sunday night football game should be
um I mean it it was a lot of calls that
went both ways a lot of Mis calls at
that um and and I think refs is getting
to the point where they're they're
controlling the game and not a positive
manner not throwing they're missing
calls um and blatant calls and they're
calling things that shouldn't be called
and and I think it's the quite opposite
they're trying to emphasize on
protecting and doing all these things so
much that they're missing the blatant uh
you know mischievous calls that should
be called in crucial times throughout
that game and it's something that we
hate to see um we turn in a bunch of
Clips every team turns in a bunch of
Clips around the league and they always
come back oh yeah this should have been
called um I just think it's time for we
hold uh refs and people uh accountable
for for these action because they're
determining games they these calls are
getting team bailing teams out on third
down uh they're bailing teams out on
third down it's actually sickening how
many sacks have been taken away across
the League this year how many roughing
the passers there have been I agree and
you know late shots on the quarterback I
know we want to keep quarterbacks on the
field it's a better game with them but
at the end I'm it's a lot of flops the
timing of the ball things like that it
it all contradicts I mean it's part of
the game we hit people like that's just
the nature of the game um and it and
it's tough um and Jaylen uh HZ the way
he played in that second half that
that's championship football and his
team played championship football uh
crucial stops um you know made Big Time
catches Big Time throws uh and and it
was huge uh and you kind of could put
jayen Herz in the MVP conversation um
just because their strength of schedule
uh who they've played um and how he's
been able to win games and clutch
moments um he could he should be in the
MVP uh he wouldn't be my leader but he
will be obviously I think he should he's
a top four uh top three candidate for
MVP um across the league and if I if I'm
naming you know two I think my two
quarterbacks uh that would be it would
be Dak and Jaylen I think they're
playing uh some of the best football
right now um and then outside of them I
think it would be Tyreek Hill we're
talking about nonf football uh Tyreek
Hill um it would be a miles Garrett or
it'll be a uh don Bland of course I
think them fers should be in this MVP
conversation um Point Blank period uh
you know I don't even think we should
even put some QBs in there because
they're not playing at the same level as
other players around the league uh
Tyreek Hill over, 1300 yards already um
first ever like this is abnormal stuff I
think this has been an abnormal season
so much greatness I think Tyre Hill is
going to break Megatron's record um
that's the type of season he's having
and I think he's going to do it
but um is it unfair to blame Josh Allen
if the bills miss the playoffs um Josh
did play a very good Net game and this
is the type of player that Josh is going
to be on a Sunday night game anytime
it's a big time game I think Josh
Allen's gonna show up um I think there
was times where his defense could have
got uh bigger stops uh bad plays on the
ball and things like that and uh kind of
really bailed them out um but their
defense also made crucial stops they
made big plays um Josh Allen's now 0 and
six in overtime games and the bills have
101 plus Point differential so that
means they're in great position they
should be winning games they shouldn't
be uh you know a under 500 team they
should be realistically a eight and
three team like most teams you know that
that is crazy like the point
differential he's playing good ball um I
just think the turnovers and the big
plays that they're giving up in crucial
times is really hurting that team and
it's painful to see because Josh Allen
yes he his turn turnovers some of his
turnovers are bad but he is playing
really good football outside of
turnovers so I hate to judge him just on
that and trust me I know how that feels
how people I think Dak was playing
really good football but he had a lot of
turnovers last year and people kind of
uh blamed him for that and kind of made
that focal point but now they're saying
this year it doesn't matter controversy
how you want to look at it but you know
turnovers uh hurt the team a lot uh it's
give and take you know I don't think
turnovers are in the world I think your
defense should get stops but they are
playing good football and Josh is
playing good football outside of the
turnovers so it's it's understandable
why people are saying it's Josh but I
really don't think it's all Josh and
that's just period just like that uh and
then obviously the best team in the East
I think in the AFC is the Ravens they
beat the Chargers Sunday night uh
they're currently 9 and3 number one seat
in the AFC um the Kansas City is the
number two seat at eight and three as a
tiebreaker over Jacksonville uh
Jacksonville took down CJ stra in
Houston on Sunday and now eight and3 and
number three SE in AFC I think the uh
Jacksonville Jaguars are a sleeper team
um there's times where Trevor Lawrence
looks amazing there's times he's not he
doesn't look the most amazing but I
think if he can play consistently
towards this December stretch and this
tough stretch that they have and going
into playoffs Jacksonville Jaguars will
surprise a lot of teams um but right now
I think uh between that Ravens defense
is one of the best in League with
Patrick Queen and roan Smith what
they're able to do together is truly
special and in their back in is playing
that Elite level right now so the Ravens
are the number one team I it's hard to
take that away from because I think Z
flowers has stepped up for them
offensively in a huge way and Odell
Beckham and Lamar is playing at MVP
level also so I don't want to also throw
out Lamar because Lamar is also playing
at MVP level um if if I'm really looking
at it um they're playing amazing right
now and then uh a comment that people
thought was controvert Trevor Lawrence
commins uh wanting the teams in his
division to be as bad as possible um
honestly you know it kind of makes
harder to win games when your team is so
good uh in a certain division um you
know uh going into it a a lot of people
said the NFC East would be one of the
best divisions in football and obviously
uh you really never know how teams are
going to pan out some te teams might hit
uh and get players they've been missing
and make crucial stops and you know turn
their season around in one year like the
Texans um so they're obviously a really
good team DeMarco Murray is turning
around completely over there in Houston
and it looks uh completely amazing what
they're doing right now but you know you
you kind of it kind of makes it harder
because you obviously play your non-
divisional games and like us we're
playing the bills we're playing the
Dolphins and their division is extremely
good and you're kind of like man I gotta
play these guys like and then I kind of
got this The Eagles I got the Giants I
got Washington who also I gota play
twice a year so it's kind of like you
almost want a break of elite competition
sometimes uh and some people says but I
always been like I want to play the best
people always I want to beat your best I
wanna uh dominate your best that's kind
of always been my mentality I don't care
who lines up it just want to be me so I
see where he's coming from but I also
see from the competitor side why you
want to beat the best it gives you
adversity it gives you uh what the
competition is going to look like for
playoffs it want of gives you hardfought
wins uh you want to earn you want to
build them calluses for something that
you gonna have in the season and I think
that's always important playing against
the best um and that's why we look
forward to playing uh teams like the
Seahawks and we play the Eagles twice a
year and the Giants and Washington cuz
they're all really good teams in our own
way the internet was freaking out
because Justin Tucker missed a field
goal I actually saw these uh they
actually said uh they was human uh
because Justin Tucker missed late left
with three minutes left in the fourth
quarter uh this is this what you call a
man that you know everything happened
everyone has a and they actually made a
question a million dollar question you
had a million dollars on the line who
you trusting seven Curry they free throw
Justin Tucker and uh I'm going be quite
honest with you love Justin Tucker but
I'm I'm G have to take Steph Curry uh
what what Justin Tucker is amazing in
his own way and what he's able to
accomplish Hall of Fame kicker for sure
but I seen I mean we've seen videos of
Steph probably hitting two 300 free
throws in a row I
mean I mean you put Steph in the gym
with no win conditions anything I'm
taking Steph Curry uh I'm putting
everything on the line for Steph uh you
know he this guy shoots over 90% from
free throw I mean that I don't think
that's a question I'm taking the best
shooter ever um in that case and
scenario and it came out this morning
the Panthers have fired head coach Frank
reach after starting season one and 10
um th this is this this troubles and
they fired their QB coach and a bunch of
other assistant head coach and things
like that uh this troubles me
because you you draft a guy number one
and you don't know what direction you're
going into um they came into the season
thinking they were going to replace DJ
Moore and they didn't replace him um
they're missing a lot of slots on the
field um you know some of your picks and
some of your players are healthy uh you
know you lose players your o Line's not
healthy um and so now you have this
number one quarterback and you give up
so much for uh Bryce young and you don't
know what direction you're going into so
now question is like you got this young
kid and they gave up DJ Moore they gave
up a first round pick uh which would be
DJ uh Darnell right uh second round pick
Tariq Stevenson and and uh actually next
year there it's the first overall pick
um and you give up all of this for a QB
right and I think Bryce young is gonna
be a great QB but I think what's crucial
that you know uh CJ stra has he has
structure they have a system they
they're building around him they're
doing everything he can be uh to make
him great uh that's what Theo Ryan's
doing and over there it's like they
don't know quite what how they want
Bryce sh to be they want to build the
system around what do they have in place
and things like that so I think that's
why it's really unfair for um to make
that statement of who's going to be the
best between CJ and Bryce because I
think they're both are crazy talented
they're both top picks for a reason um
but the it just I just don't understand
the move um because they they had uh
their head coach last year um you know
who coaches at Nebraska now and it's
like how many times you going to keep
changing coaches you going bring guys in
before you give a chance to say hey this
is our guy we are going to uh bring
we're going to build around him um and
we're gonna you know make this guy force
us to win games and change the culture I
think a lot of it deals with culture if
you don't have a culture winning you
don't have a culture attitude it leads
to failures and right if you don't have
a guy that's there long enough to build
a culture um like I I would give a
perfect example uh Dan Campbell right
the Lions when he first got there I
think they went uh a little under 500
they might have been eight and eight and
then next year they made the playoffs
and this year um they top five team in
the NFC uh that's a guy who build a
culture of the way culture he wanted BR
his guys in said this is who we are this
is what it is um and he's building a
winning culture with guys I think that's
the type of guy that the Panthers need
they need a guy that's going to come in
and believe in him I think he turned
around jarro Go's career a lot of ways
um and that's always special to see uh
because a lot of people thought jarro G
going to Detroit it was over for him
he's going to be at the league but
obviously he's winning full G and
playing some of his best football right
now um with that great team they have
over so uh you need a culture driver
person that's going to come in and I
think same way for the uh the way that
the Raiders are trying to change their
culture right now with their uh new
assistant coach right now um so that's
the type of prayer uh I mean coach that
the Panthers I feel is they need and
they should go after um and some coaches
I'm not sure what coach they need I
think they need to go uh above and
beyond and research and a guide that
they truly believe is gonna change the
culture um and you know um if we did
lose a guy like Dan Quinn um this
offseason I think Dan Quin would be an
amazing guy uh for this type of job you
know and and and that's just me uh
personally because I know Dan and I know
type of culture he brings how he makes
guys believe in him and do things like
that I mean Dan is truly amazing I mean
he is the uh one of the best coaches I
ever been a part of uh he is a pure
culture guy and uh he does amazing
things and he is just so uh he's just a
man with many words and visions that I
think he spreads love and awareness uh
across the room so uh that's a guy I
truly believe in and I'm going to get
into my next topic because this is
something where I kind of been hitting
on um when I said that the league is
offensive league and Tom Brady kind of
hit on it it was a clip going around
last week Tom Brady saying there's a lot
of mocy in today's NFL and let's listen
I think there's a lot of mediocrity in
today's NFL I don't see the Excellence
that I saw in the past why not and why
not I think the coaching isn't as as
good as it was I don't think the
development of young players is as good
as it was the rules have allowed a lot
of bad habits to get into the actual
performance of the game so I just think
the product in my opinion is less than
what it's been I think I look at a lot
of players like Ray Lewis and Rodney
Harrison and Ronnie lot and guys that
impacted the game in in a certain way
and every hit they would have made would
have been a penalty you hear coaches
complaining about their own player being
tackling and not necessarily why don't
they talk to their player about how to
protect himself we used to work on the
fundamentals of those things all the
time now they're trying to be regulated
all the time offensive players need to
protect themselves it's not up to the
defensive player to protect offensive
player a defensive player needs to
protect himself I didn't throw the ball
to certain areas because I was afraid
players was going to get knocked out
that's the reality I didn't throw it to
the middle when I played Ray Lewis
because you knock him out of the game
and I couldn't afford to lose a good
player I I kind of uh without a doubt
100% agree um you look at today's NFL
with a lot of QBs flopping on hits uh
you're looking at guys who are you know
kind of flailing they they hit them hard
they Le with their shoulder and it looks
like it's a helmet to helmet they get
fine 40,000 they're trying to protect
these these guys um the blinds side hits
I agree should be taken out um but
there's a lot of things a lot of hits
that you can make you can't leave your
feet when you're making a hit um this is
100% correct they're protecting a
certain amount of guys uh so that way
they like a guy perfect example uh
Kareem Jackson's been fined an an absurd
amount absurd amount this year I believe
over
$100,000 um and all the hits he made
were very legal hits but because guyses
are trying to slide or they don't know
how to protect themselves or they're not
sliding in time they are finding this
man and suspending this man of games
because he is playing football the right
way uh I think Tom even at a point in
his career he he took advantage of the
rule change and he let that be in his
favor he let these rules that they knew
they were changing into his favor even
cha would look for cause and say uh you
know you know and this is true Tom will
look for late hits he will look for you
know know uh if his if his wide receiver
got hit the wrong way and he would
sometimes get those calls and that's
just the reality of it the league has
went more into the offensive League
they're trying to protect and keep QBs
because guys like Desa Watson out for
the rest of the Year Joe burrow uh Kurt
Cousins they're trying to do their best
to protect these guys and lead them on
the field and that's just the reality I
don't think that the league is trending
the right way and you kind of see it a
little bit in college football college
football has been going downhill a lot
you know High School football has been
going down the hill a lot and it's just
been uh streaming upwards they like it
it's like a trail that never ends of bad
football being played from high school
all the way up from the Tendencies the
coaching has not been uh right they
haven't been teaching these guys mowing
these guys into men uh teaching these
guys the fundamentals of what it means
to be a player on and off the field and
that's just the reality of it and it and
it's leaking into the NFL and it's just
getting worse and worse um and I just
don't think it's the same love and
protection towards defensive players at
that uh so it I 100% agree with Tom I
think there's players and there's teams
that takes advantage of these rules uh
the fact that you know a quarterback can
run at you full speed One play and give
himself up and then the next time act
like he's sliding or he may you may
think he's about to slide and he could
Juke out and you go with the same energy
and you hit him because you don't know
if he's fake sliding or he is sliding
and you might get a penalty and you
might get a letter in the mail because
you you late hit this quarterback I just
think it's right ridiculous like like
there you either can hit the guy or you
can't like I don't think there should be
a uh in out there shouldn't be a certain
rule where oh well if he gives himself
up well you're playing football at full
speed you're not playing football at 50%
like I think that's the retive like
you're playing football to hit the other
team and get your team in the best
position to win you're not worried about
what this guy is doing like I'm not I
can't focus on tackling this guy while
I'm focused on oh my gosh this guy
sliding I need to get this guy to the
ground um so this is this is something
that's mindboggling to me um it's like
very short gaps and there's very and
especially there's ones when the
quarterback's throwing it out you're
pass ruping you're clearing a guy and
just as you get there you're hitting the
QB or you might try to sack him thinking
he's still the ball um and you could get
a flag and you could get a roughing
passes so guys are you know almost
scared or you got to make sure the QB
has the ball uh that's split second can
be different so you get a sack or not so
I think this is the truth and the
reality of this uh but you know I 100%
agree on what Tom Brady's saying uh
what's the best part about playing
Thursday Night Football I guess the best
part about playing on Thursday night is
you're the show right you know
everyone's watching you um you get an
opportunity to go out there and compete
um and there's no other game uh so you
kind of be the show and you kind of make
your presence phone and be the best uh
in the
NFL uh did what have I seen from Gino
Smith and the Seahawks I see a very good
team uh goo's been playing good football
once again uh you know the record really
don't show us how good they lost a very
close one I think if anything this team
could be a eight and3 team uh for sure
without a doubt um so uh we definitely
got our hands full it's gonna be a great
game Thursday night football and can't
wait to see you all there let's take
some final questions from the
chat uh Shaq imog at Shaq lonard Jersey
are you telling us something I'm not
telling you nothing yet uh we'll see
next week what happens uh when he comes
to visit on the edge tune in to that uh
and check this see if Shaq is going to
be a Dallas Cowboy or not uh who do you
got 49ers or Eagle Sunday uh this one
I'm going just keep my mouth shut I
think it's just gonna be a great game
another great game it's gonna be a fun
game uh and I'll be looking to see if
the 49ers can redeem themselves this is
the 40 fully healthy 49ers they get a
longer breaker than the Eagles so they
get more preparation uh so it'll be very
interesting to see how this game goes
there's been a lot of talk back and
forth between the Eagles and 49ers so
it's going to be a very good game to see
did you see jamus whipping rapping on
the sideline would you would you be
Derek Carr uh yeah I actually did see
that video um I was a little confused uh
and honestly I would have started
rapping back with uh Derek Carr you know
what I'm saying like I honestly would
love to be on Jam's team for one year
just to see how he truly is like he is
this man is a pure character um thought
on the no call on the Josh Allen horse
caller uh honestly if the quarterback's
still in the pocket that they can horse
collar you are allowed to grab a
quarterback by the horse collar if
they're still in the pocket um thoughts
on the Broncos five-game winning streak
uh I think this is why you send a first
round pick for Shawn Payton uh Russell
Wilson's playing at an elite level right
now this is the Russell Wilson that uh
people plan to get when they drafted for
him I think they're showing him why they
invested in him why they brought him in
uh he's proven a lot of people wrong and
I love to see it uh this is the Russell
Wilson Shawn pay connection that a lot
of people people thought uh that it
would be and it's great to see that they
turning things around even after they
got rid of a lot of players where a lot
of people anticipate like Randy Gregory
and things like
that uh who is the biggest X Factor on
the Seahawks I think the biggest X
Factor on the Seahawks is Gino you know
I think if Gino's playing lights out
he's playing the elite ball uh there's
no one they're they're hard to beat you
know I think when he's in Rhythm and
he's doing what he does best uh they're
very hard to beat and he's the ultimate
competitor your QB is always got to be
your your biggest X Factor uh what is
your CLE for claws um I'm actually doing
a CLE for clause for uh Harrisburg
hospitals uh you know supporting young
uh women and children uh that's in
hospitals and uh it's GNA be very
amazing uh Dak is MVP stat would be even
better if he wasn't sitting out in the
fourth quarter most the time 100% agree
uh when we're at home dak's missing in
the fourth quarter um he's probably sing
the Bene rooting for other guys I mean
he's playing Elite level and I don't
think no one should take that away from
him um and and that's just just the
reality of I think uh just because his
record isn't uh you know the best and
he's still competing I think he's
playing some of the best football in
National Football League and as simple
as that he's almost top five in every
category as a QB which is very hard to
do who is your biggest inspiration uh my
biggest inspiration is my family my kids
man uh you know they they they my
they're my pride and joy um they give me
everything I need uh you know they they
give me they're my reason why uh they're
the things that um
you know I just they just really you
know when I come home and they scream my
name and they look forward to see me it
really makes my day uh it's something
truly special uh so my kids would be my
biggest inspiration uh if you got kids
you understand they they give you
everything in life they give you uh your
why they give you uh you know because
you got to raise them in such a certain
manner we talk about kids every day and
almost in the dine room and how we
should raise our kids and uh give us
feedback so um our my kids will be uh my
true inspiration but anyway I thank
y'all for tuning in to the edge live in
the B Report app uh thank you for T
giving me your time your ears and I this
opportunity to drop gaming know and Y
I'll see y'all next week back on the
edge with your boy Michael Parson thank
you and appreciate
you